Trump's filling the bench with his
appointments and it looks like the
establishment is finally catching on we
have the largest number of federal
judicial vacancies to be filled since
the early 1950s Trump is rapidly
reshaping the judiciary breaking down
the speed at which federal appeals
courts are filling up with young
conservative judges extraordinarily
unqualified people including for
judicial nominees who've been dubbed
unqualified by the American Bar
Association which is extremely rare yeah
extremely rare like an electric car
owner that doesn't tell you about it
immediately don't listen to that noise
these judges aren't unqualified they're
on inside they're Outsiders and we need
more Outsiders on the courts Outsiders
like Trump judicial nominee Leonard
Steven Graz he's got three names so you
know he's good like Lee Harvey Oswald's
note okay uh Mary Kate ash you know what
just trust me he's just a regular guy
who supports gay conversion therapy and
was deemed not qualified by the American
Bar Association in a unanimous 14 to
zero vote who do you think you are ABA
calling him unanimously not qualified
it's like last weekend when I was deemed
unanimously sloshed by all the bottle
waitresses at Ruby Tuesday's say what
you want but I came to that salad bar to
party
and Trump's latest unanimously
unqualified Rockstar nominee check it
out I love this guy
Brett Talley he is 36 years old
he's been practicing law for give or
take three years and importantly he has
never tried a case in court awesome
me too you know who else never tried a
case in court Tom Cruise and a few good
men and he won that case at least I
think he did I turned it off when I
realized that Kevin Bacon wasn't Kiefer
Sutherland's Brett tally sailed through
the nominating committee on a party-line
vote so he could be confirmed to the
bench as early as this week now he
caught some flak because when asked if
he had any connections to the
administration he failed to disclose
that his wife is chief of staff to the
White House Counsel I think that's a
plus how refreshing to see a power
couple keeping their relationship
private for once
I mean Chrissy Teigen we get it John
Legend loves you you don't need a
snapchat every time he touches the small
of your back as tallies confirmation
gets close I already know the argument
the libs are preparing to launch
diversity o
tallies another white guy and Trump's
judicial appointees are 91 percent white
and 81 percent male and 100 percent
think that the worst superhero movie was
Wonder Woman yes but Trump's nominees
are diverse and I'm more than
comfortable having this diversity
conversation but Nicole will be doing
most of the talking Nicole Thurmond
everyone
talk to me it am i right here oh
absolutely Jordan Trump's judicial
nominees are incredibly diverse it's not
like that old-fashioned mainstream
diversity though with the focus on
different races and genders no no we
need a more diverse kind of diversity
I'm talking about alt diversity which is
a diversity of ideas and levels of
experience a deeper diversity like Bret
tally isn't just a white guy with no
practical law experience he's also an
author of horror novels now these are
actual published books that this judge
wrote haunted Alabama black belts and
the fiddle is the devil's instrument yes
and and here's a fact the devil is the
fiddle player in Mumford & Sons a band
full of liberal vest propaganda it's
disgusting but the most diverse thing
about Bret tally is that he's a ghost
hunter mm-hmm in 2010 he was a member of
the Tuscaloosa paranormal research group
that is no doubt a deeply scientific
group of people who run around at night
trying to find that bitch from the ring
who keeps jumping out my TV
let's say they call makes me happy
finally a male Ghostbuster pay attention
Hollywood that's a movie we want to see
Jordan this is real okay it is so real
in fact that this photo of Tali were
using is him in a graveyard mm-hmm it's
the only it's the only licensed photo of
him we could find that is how dedicated
he is to the paranormal yes and you know
he's a great ghost hunter because I
haven't seen a ghost like ever me either
and if he brings a fraction of his ghost
hunting skills to the courtroom he's
gonna be a great judge the best judge
not like those Obama judges like sure he
is diversity focused on nominating a
record number of women and people of
color but there were zero ghost hunters
all right no Bigfoot believers RL Stein
wasn't even considered for the 8th
circuit that is so close-minded are
these the kind of skeptics you want
making life-and-death decisions in the
courtroom no we need more molders on the
bench less skully's and Brett Talley is
the kind of judge who will see the truth
and dead people